cellulite ça finirait se reproduirait
Amin sur Alabama
música visitant le satellite Olav de
Ptolémée comme massage à Detroit la ba
la France vaciller en un rien de temps seules victimes
d'Europe en 2017 j'ai été violée par une
collègue quand je suis allée me faire avorter
il y avait  les manifestants à l'extérieur de la
clinique n'assassinent pas l'homme pour le meurtre
ne verront pas le royaume des cieux
tu es un meurtrier
tu vas en enfer tu sais comment
tu pourrais tuer un
bébé c'est un lieu de mort cette interdiction a été
introduite était de  apaiser les
gens évangéliques conservateurs extrêmes cette
image ce n'est pas un extrémiste sur la ciabatta
maman était dans un bistrot sait qu'il y a
tout - nous avons une cendre de coton était-ce fait
à Apollo avouer l'Américain le font-ils
mais il obtient le funky différent Lord one
jetable libéral comme  tant qu'il y a des
gens sur le trottoir qui
traitent les gens comme ils le font
dans cette clinique, je serai ici
sensei alors il viendra financer une ancienne
division Zetas uni est un copain pallie pauvre en
bas tout  isabella mauvais choix ensemble
édification pro raduardo choisir oopah
de oaxaca interruption causes bureau
versa pour la vie d'alep la cagoule est ton
berceau pas une sueur de cellules souches abajo querelle
chaque édifice dirige tout arizo socio
regarde un hospice parmi amo le centre commercial en
effet faire Danny Kenickie projet niveau
Timon  Alabama 5 heures du matin 7
ou toute personne déjà ici pour tuer
leur bébé Jésus-Christ est le bordel du Seigneur
bienvenue aux portes de l'enfer
mon ami a regardé Jésus un jour
je fais confiance au Seigneur mec j'aime ton bébé
Dieu te connaît mec
il s'est empressé de marcher dans le bébé, d'
accord, ignorez-les, nous avons donc utilisé des parapluies
pour protéger le patient de nos
manifestants, nous l'utilisons comme ça pour les empêcher
de filmer et de prendre des photos et de
violer autrement leur vie privée
qui a été expulsée de son école et
a fait payer toute son école et
ils lui ont pris cela, il
y a donc des conséquences réelles à être
ici et à être film  ed et avoir votre
photo sur Facebook ou Twitter ou
Instagram cette personne pourrait être blessée
voire tuée si sa famille est
anti-avortement ou si vous connaissez l'
anti-avortement de leur église leurs employeurs
anti-avortement ils peuvent être renvoyés de
leur travail ils peuvent perdre  toute leur
communauté à cause de la stigmatisation à laquelle
ils sont confrontés autour des soins d'avortement en
Alabama
où est Lana la plupart de ma fille chante pour
une raison quelconque vous avez une caméra pour montrer aux
autres chrétiens ici Montgomery regardez
ce qui se passe regardez ce que les gens
regardent la façon dont les gens agissent  à part
Jésus je n'essaie pas de faire honte aux femmes
mais je vous dis ceci je n'ai pas de
problème à montrer leur visage ces femmes je les
aime mais elles commettent un
crime elles commettent un crime de
meurtre mais je montre  le monde comme
vous les gars madame je vous aime aujourd'hui écoutez
ce n'est pas la réponse madame craintivement
et merveilleusement fait c'est votre bébé c'est vrai
vous avez toute votre vie vous avez votre
carrière madame et vous pouvez le faire avec votre
bébé bien madame regardez Jésus ne
regardez pas la clinique choisissez la vie il y a
encore 25 bébés tués presque chaque semaine
une classe de maternelle exterminée
tout le monde s'inquiète des armes à feu qu'en est-
il du meurtre d'innocents chaque semaine
aujourd'hui j'ai rejoint ma foi avec d'autres
croyants et  m'engager à prier de
ne jamais me taire et d'être actif dans le
mouvement pro-vie que vous délivrez dans
la région du
bien mal et de l'éco Alabama est un minuscule
conservatoire p.m.  vous vous asseyez sur la lune
Suzuki j'approuverais insulté une
remise à zéro de la clinique Marcella meilleure télévision sur Sofia quarante
LSVT gardellin anima réduisant pour le
massage Dubrow Posen Satya oh enfer nah
dr.  Mowat sur schwa
alors lisez oh aucun permis de tenir le téléphone
ne peut me traverser mon choix est mon
choix peu importe si vous l'aimez ou si
vous ne l'aimez pas vous pouvez crier et
crier sur moi tout ce que vous voulez et vous pourriez
m'envoyer  Je vais mourir brûlé en enfer
que je devrais vouloir prendre soin de cet
enfant Je peux faire mes autres je fais c'est pourquoi
je choisis de le faire parce que je ne peux pas
faire pour cet enfant et donc tu es pro-vie
anti-avortement mais qu'en est-il de ce bébé
une fois qu'il sera là tu ne seras plus là
pour prendre soin de cet enfant oui tu dis que
tu peux m'aider comment tu vas
m'aider tu vas être là à chaque étape
du chemin tu peux payer  pour mes
factures d'hôpital est-ce que tu vas payer pour l'
éducation de cet enfant non tu ne veux pas que
j'aille dans cette clinique et ils sucent ce
bébé parce qu'après la naissance du bébé
tu t'en fous de ce qui
arrive à cet enfant
Alabama  supprimer Montserrat agacé
généralement Bo Cooper Marco, ils pourraient
présenter des limites strictes sur un
bott particulier  om oh vous savez qu'ils essaient d'
assassiner le gars vous savez qui ce
médecin le premier médecin que les manifestants anti-juifs
ont tué travaillait dans notre clinique L'
Alabama a une mauvaise histoire était la violence
envers les fournisseurs d'avortement
nous avons cette histoire vous savez qui dit que l'
équilibre est quelque chose qui  pourrait surgir
à tout moment, vous ne savez jamais les
entreprises Manu sur te regem Gunilla corps
politique résonnent Alabama avati sur Madrid
est Nev quand vous êtes là-bas le diesel est une
interruption cause son mmoca
Deauville insisterait IDO Vinick WA alors ce que je
déchire conduit un verre de  avancement sénateur
torsion ISM trop fort pour attacher de l'alcool
savez-vous ce que c'est que d'être violée
non madame je ne sais pas ce que
c'est d'avoir un parent qui commet un inceste sur
vous sur moi non madame oui sur vous  donc pour enlever
ce choix à cette personne qui
a subi un acte aussi traumatisant
contre elle pour qu'elle reste avec le résidu
de cette personne si vous voulez, pourquoi ne voudriez-vous
pas qu'une femme ait au moins cette
exception pour un tel  un acte horrible
sénateur chambliss avez-vous une petite
fille
sénateur cela ne concerne pas ma famille et
je ne suis que des questions axonales permettez-moi de
dire à ceux d'entre vous qui ont une petite
fille fermez les yeux un instant vous
venez de dire à mon  petite fille ma petite
fille aimante que tu peux juste être
violée ou une de tes pommes ou ton
cousin de quelqu'un pourrait juste te violer
et t'imprégner et tu dois porter
ce bébé sous la loi de l'Alabama
[Musique]
il est important qu'il n'y ait pas d'
exceptions pour  le viol et l'inceste parce
que cela serait incompatible avec l'
argument juridique selon lequel l'enfant à naître est
une personne, nous utilisons la définition de
notre code pénal qui existe déjà
pour l'homicide pour meurtre si vous tuez une
femme enceinte et dites qu'elle est enceinte de deux
trois mois  alors vous êtes
accusé d'un double meurtre et donc de la
même manière, nous disons que si vous prenez
la vie de cet enfant par un avortement,
alors c'est un meurtre aujourd'hui, nous avons tenu
une autre promesse que mon administration a
p  a proposé une nouvelle règle pour interdire le
financement du titre dix d'aller à toute clinique
qui pratique des avortements un
président pro-vie un vice-président
pro-vie une chambre des représentants
pro-vie et vingt-cinq capitales d'État républicaines pro-vie, ce
qui est plutôt bien
[Applaudissements  ]
il fait juste beaucoup de
bruit et tout, mais les gens
autour de lui qui prennent des décisions et
font des choses pour lui, je pense qu'ils
font du bon travail et je suis d'accord avec ça
comme les juges qu'il a mis à la Cour
suprême
[Musique  ]
Salade de sequa lacustre Koda restiess
American repo life Sundays I'm a
majority
lalu a vote in Alabama immediate male
Antechinus tisp a lady phone service
with des Ami Saito's otra cosa creme de
pochomil see we know la la terre des
Olav Ottoman Alabama alcool illégal non
problema mo le célèbre dévot de Cordova en
Alabama certains ont décidé de développer une
ordonnance, etc. Eric jusqu'à son arrestation WA
Celica de cemento Blakely la TV seule
personne collegia douzo induit les
gens Revati ne le font pas  comprenez vraiment ce qui
arrive à votre corps quand vous êtes
enceinte,
il subit des changements et on vous le
rappelle constamment je me sentais malade et je
me sentais très mal et je n'ai pas pu gérer
ça pendant neuf mois je ne pouvais tout simplement pas je
n'ai pas dit grand-chose  des gens à propos de mon
viol ou de mon avortement parce que j'avais peur
de la honte et de la stigmatisation qui
accompagnent ces deux personnes ne vous croient
pas quand vous dites que vous avez été violée
ici parfois les gens ne croient pas qu'il
y a une raison  jamais
avorter,
j'ai entendu des gens dire que c'est comme si
nous vivions à l'âge de pierre ou que
nous reculions au lieu d'avancer
et je pense que c'est une méthode de contrôle
que beaucoup de partis conservateurs extrêmes utilisent
essayer de pousser
c'est quelque chose avec lequel je lutte beaucoup
si je dois rester en Alabama et essayer
de l'améliorer ou si je dois simplement
m'enfuir,
j'ai vraiment l'impression que je dois à
nouveau traverser le traumatisme parce que je me sens
ému de raconter mon histoire  aux législateurs
même en publi  c
beaucoup de gens connaissent mon histoire mais c'est
très important pour moi qu'ils sachent comment
cela affecte les gens comme moi les Alabamiens
les gens ordinaires
[Musique]